this priority is about a community-led  approach to health and well-being it's  about working closer and smarter  together with our communities too  use our collective skills to reach a  common goal we can all contribute  together to create a more connected  communities  make use of the local resources and so  the people know where to go to get the  help that is needed and to bounce back  from adversity  while our communities have needs that  are complex and interlinked they also  have our assets  that can help people with their  resilience  it is important that we use the  resources well that we might have in the  skills and the knowledge in the  buildings and the green spaces  [Music]